in only a few weeks a new gun is coming
to valerant for the first time ever it
has the potential to completely change
the game but from what we know so far
will the outlaw be
busted all right before we talk about
valerent new gun I need you to check out
our new merch collection including our
onward and forward shirt so head over to
shop.the score.com to check it out all
right so a couple months ago I made a
video about a potential new sniper
coming to valerant some leaks came out
on the Chinese platform Billy Billy
showing a gun called The Outlaw sitting
between the operator and the Marshall
costing 2400 credits now in the 3 and
1/2 years since valerant came out Riot
has never released a new weapon and
honestly we might not even need one but
regardless when people saw these leaks a
couple months back everyone including
myself began theorizing how the outlaw
might actually work in game and the most
obvious answer was that it would combat
the current light Shields meta for those
of you who don't know NRG implement
mented this strategy against Ghost last
year and fnatic popularized it
throughout this year and clearly they
saw a lot of success the idea is that
you can spend less money and build up
your economy so that you can secure more
buys throughout the match and it often
won't make or break around sure it means
that you can get one tapped from 15 to
30 m from a phantom but if you get
gushed with full armor then it's pretty
likely your opponent is going to secure
that kill Anyways full armor just
doesn't always feel necessary especially
if you know that your opponent's
typically only buy vandals so because of
this I speculated that the outlaw would
likely do somewhere around 126 to 130
damage as a direct counter to the light
Shields meta but yesterday more leaks
came out and it looks like this gun
might be even stronger this tweet from
valerant update says that it will deal
body damage of around 140 will debut
with non-animated skins and fire two
bullets at a time like a Shorty Mike
from valer leaks also tweeted that the
outlaw will be added with the launch of
episode 8 early next year so in my eyes
it's basically confirmed now it's called
the outw right is a sniper or what
that's kind of cool I kind of with that
fires two bullets at a time kills half
armored enemies with a single shot body
damage around 140 no animated skins is a
bummer for a skin fiend like myself but
when they say that this gun will fire
two bullets at once like a shorty I'm
pretty sure they're referring to the bag
size the shorty technically fires 15
pellets in a single shot so I think they
just worded this poorly and now there's
a lot of confusion within the community
that being said MCE did have interesting
theory on platchat yesterday that I'm
willing to entertain he brought up the
blaze break action rifle from DayZ which
has two firing modes one mode has a high
rate of fire and shoots two bullets at
once while the other has a low rate of
fire and shoots one bullet at a time so
the high fire rate mode would deal one
140 damage like valerant update suggests
and the low fire rate mode would deal
reduced damage I think that this is a
cool Theory but I'm pretty sure when
they say two bullets at a time they're
referring to the mag size either way
this new information has everyone
calling the outlaw the the light Shields
killer there's finally a weapon that can
kill opponents with light armor with a
single body shot and this could have
massive implications on the overall
economy and valerant we can't buy half
it has an outlaw I I can see people hero
buying it I mean it's 2.4 though you
need to be up big you could buy it and
half armor every round right as someone
who buys a frenzy and invests in a bit
of util on most of my eco rounds this
does seem a bit worrying if I continue
to buy light shields on my buy rounds
then I'll likely get punished a lot more
often than I do now but although a lot
of people are maybe jumping the gun and
calling the outlaw busted before it even
comes out I think that it might be good
for the overall health of the game I've
interviewed and talked to a hell of a
lot of Pros over the past few years and
throughout many of those discussions a
lot of them have complained that
valerent sometimes just feels way too
random I even spoke to Chronicle
valerent most decorated player only a
few weeks ago and he had something
similar to say it's already random you
can't predict anything that's why people
have inconsistent performances all the
time I mean one tournament for example
or like one ranking game you can play
like a God and after that you the next
one you're playing in 0.5 KD I mean it
just hard hard to play this game right
now even for pro players I think a lot
of the randomness that valerant players
sometimes experience can be attributed
to the guns we've all seen what cheaper
weapons like the frenzy Stinger or judge
can do in certain situations and we've
all molded when we get Eed by but this
is where I think that the outlaw can
shine at 2400 credits it's a serious
alternative to the bulldog and guardian
which are already sometimes purchased in
place of the Phantom or Vandal I think
players will continue to buy these
weapons and might even continue to buy
light Shields but now that there's
another gun capable of one-shotting you
gaining an economic Advantage should
feel better A lot of people are already
pointing out that the outlaw could be an
absolute monster on antio rounds and I
agree but I don't necessarily see that
as a bad thing when I win a pistol round
I should be be confident and feel like
I'm at an advantage and sure I'll
probably still get eced every once in a
while when this gun gets added to the
game but what I'm saying is that I don't
think it will be as game-breaking as
some people seem to think maybe that
take will age like milk but I'm
interested to hear what you guys have to
say do you think that the outlaw is a
good addition of allant or an
unnecessary one will 2024 bring us an
entirely new meta I think the name is
sick I think like the outlaw and the
Vandal and stuff like that like I think
are cool names then you have the
operator though I think of the snipers
it's by far the coolest I I agree I
think it's by far the cool and I think
it also looks the
coolest based on what we've seen so far
at least